ce sont les militaires et bertrand qui
font forlan est bien plus jolie nolwenn
son énergie nos de marne aux leçons sans
oublier avec
des colis
laissant du coup
tout ceci
on voit des heures sur le béton
c'est la magie meilleurs champions les
animaux
le pays
il nous offre
bonjour cette émission spéciale cuisine
que nous vous proposons aujourd'hui
qu'ils aient posé dans la fin
on est bien
la belgique
il attend
un vaisseau si on s'amuse on chante
on réfléchit ça n'était pas du mercredi
il m'a pris
mac os 10
jeudi
un jour j'espère qu'on fait tous en
pleine forme à 2h spéciale 6 10 ans avec
up
bonjour à tous de tort le conducteur le
conducteur oui mais oui voila voila bon
conducteur voilà vous avez le programme
voilà le programme verra le programme et
toutes les missions avec les minutage en
fait oui attention avec les mii du tage
et puis alors tâche est de suivre
correctement je suis déjà très très très
très bien nous allons voir
scooby doo et est mort a doucement je
n'étais pas demander d'annoncer ce qu'on
me dit ah non non non choisie que soit
dit regarde c'est bien ce qui est écrit
ici à cet endroit là pourquoi moi je
pourrais pas l'annoncer e scooby doo
parce que jusqu'à nouvel ordre c'est moi
qui présente cette émission quoi nous on
ne peut rien dire alors moi je dis
scooby doo le chien le plus malin de
tous les chiens
voilà non non tu es toi non
nous voulons présenter scooby doo et
nous voulons présenter broken noc et
nous voulons participer activement à
cette émission
nous voulons des responsabilités voilà
écoutez vous avez déjà un conducteur où
tout est inscrit 1
alors si vous voulez éventuellement
vache peut vous donner quelques
responsabilités en commun oui attendez
que je réfléchisse comme par exemple pas
tenez je vous propose la distribution
des petits pains chauds comme des petits
pains de cola ou son côté paula non mais
si si c'est écrit mais c'était crime
mais pas pour maintenant maintenant
regardez maintenant ils étaient ce cri
inscrit scooby doo
le titre c'est le gorille au cinéma
alors regardons d'abord scooby doo les
petits pains au chocolat plus tard le
bruit mat italie
guy drut je sais pas sorti ses primes en
didry je ne sais pas si les les hamsters
court très vite mais nous allons le
savoir grâce à ajac très malins qui va
nous raconter une histoire d'âme statut
vous raconter devant les enfants
le hamster a très bien parce que
autrefois on connaissait un seul hamster
un villa hamster gris qui habite en
alsace et en allemagne on détestait
parce qu'il fait des stocks énormes dans
son terrier ont trouvé 60 81 kg de
grains alors penché gratia me daems
terre dans un champ et reste plus grand
chose dans les met pas et puis en 1838
il ya un savant nommé waterhouse qui
dans le désert de syrie là-bas voit un
petit hamster doré comme celui que vous
connaissez comme les vôtres un seul il
le voit est l'organe comprends pas il le
décrit il sera son temps après en 1930
un savant d'alexandrie le professeur à
ronnie va dans le même désert ils
cherchaient des scorpions lui le court
après un scorpion rad soc scorpions
creusent la terre bras grappillant
scorpions et tombe dans un trou sur une
mer hamster et ses douze petits c'était
bien faire dorer comme les vôtres c'est
bien le faire dorer vous connaissez tous
vous avez tous eu il y tient c'est
l'animal quoi des rats où j'avais
découvert ce formidable email tout dans
un peigne et rentre chez lui et said est
le messie hamster la plupart crève et il
en envoie 4 au professeur adler à
londres au muséum de loin au british
muséum pour étudier la ville ces petits
hamsters là les savants se penche sur
ces hamsters les études il regarde
comment sa vie combien de temps sa porte
avant tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur
hamster du moins il le seul figure
seulement et hamsters ça se reproduit et
à la cadence de six petits tous les
trois mois
au bout de deux ans le politiste museum
était plat de hamster cet enfer
heureusement il y avait les gardes du
british muséum il y avait les
professeurs qui avaient des enfants et
cause de votre âge qui avait plus et
hamsters qu'ils aiment c'est joli comme
tout hamster donnez-les nous on leur
donne des petits hamsters et les enfants
commencent à étudier le hamster et ils
découvrent sur le mc oran tas de choses
qu ils savent on n'avait jamais vu par
exemple que un hamster on peut le
prendre comme on veut quand il a la
bouche pleine vous savez il transporte
ses provisions dans sa bouche ali fait
des grosses gouttes
alors quoi tu allais les joues pleines
comme ça on peut le prendre le car et
c'est très riche et très facile mais
quand il a vidé sa bouche avec ce n'est
pas parce qu'ils la vident avec ses
pattes
il vaut mieux faire attention parce
qu'il pourrait peut-être vous mordre et
puis découvre aussi que l'homme
r et d'un véritable pitre mais un pitre
quand vous l'avez un petit hamster dans
vingt ans dans sa cage où il donnait une
petite chaise une petite échelle un
tourniquet comme aux écureuils mais
vraiment il fait le clown mais
littéralement pour vous amuser comme
s'ils faisaient exprès et voilà que les
gosses qui raconte ses histoires sur les
acheteurs et tout le monde avait des
histoires de abstrait la suisse a
devancé 10 mais non d'un chien ses
enfants il y avait à ce moment là des
millions le hamster à travers
l'angleterre et la france vont à des
tous connus des hamsters bon et savants
se disait le chien ces gars sont vus sur
le hamster beaucoup de choses que nous
n'avions découverte nous si on allait
voir au désert les vrais hamster les
hamsters sauvage comment il faut aussi
gens aussi intelligents que ce que les
gosses raconte comprenez pour comprendre
si c'était l'éducation tout ceci c'est
naturel on part en déserts de syrie là
où le professeur arne y avait trouvé ses
treize hamster on trouve pas on
quadrille le désert mais on le passif
également au peigne fin
on a pu trouver un seul abstraire les 13
hamster que le professeur a à ronnie
avait découvert en 1930 et elle est
dernier de l'espèce et l'espèce qui
compte maintenant des millions et des
millions de lats terre a été
littéralement sauvé parce que vous les
gosses vous avez élevé rehab ster et
vous avez appris à jouer avec eux
gardent d'ailleurs ce sont des gens
absolument charmant
copains
c'est à moi pour vous voilà à ce genre
hamas et gagne encore inutile ou rien il
disait que qu'il fait beau je refuse de
continuer à jouer
citons ces pièces ne se tait pas enfin
il a droit d'être en guerre nous rien ne
prouve qu'ils ne te donne pas des
indications sur mon jeu aucune précision
n'a pas confiance n'a pas à prendre son
langage dont je joue à ce très bref je
viens de jouer cette carte il y à une
minute
tu as triché nous ont pas du tout du
goût de bouger seulement souhaité avoir
un temps de trajet plus apparu vingt six
mois magie en quelques lignes aurait que
tu avais un tel don de magicien tu peux
ainsi faire apparaître n'importe quoi et
pour moi c'est très facile tu peux me
faire une démonstration démonstration
que vous évidemment on est déjà sûr qui
s'est par exemple je pourrais moi je
pourrais te faire un autre classique du
lapin qui sort du chapeau
malheureusement nous n'avons pas de
chapeau erreur je reviens dans la
réserve ça vous a donc parfaite d'un
petit faut que je me souvienne de la
delà de la formule magique pour les
lapins chats plus rapide lucia pi doo
wop alors ça ne semble pas être un temps
en temps il a mangé j'ai oublié un nous
attends je recommence chapiteau rapide
on lapide aux chapélies bus bof bof
alors rien ouah ça alors je comprends
pas attends je juge je recommence
toute la science tu m'as pas n'importe
qui avec un + d'autrement peut faire
apparaître lapin du chapeau nantais qui
sauve toi jane au chapiteau lapidus
rapibus la payons à niveau ça chapeau
et le geôlier un snack a bien évidemment
je comprends ouais regarde il n'y avait
plus d'un chapeau une puce ouais à la
mort des lapins et il a fait fuir ou ça
use
au fond on regarde une puce qui a mordu
le lapin qui était le chapeau je le vois
rien et comment était-il ses lapins ou
maintenant franchement vous mais qui les
commet et et et j'en sais rien taquin
engagé un détective à moi je suis c'est
donc j'y suis je ne vois pas ta puce et
tu as inventé toute cette histoire de
magie pour me cacher que tu triches aux
cartes
et bien si tu n'avoues pas c'est plus
qui était dans le chapeau du mal à
sentir regarder sur toi oulala à sam 4 à
12 ans je regardais plus de rappels
lâche ne pas vous rappel cette version
de m
guy drut
fortis est vraiment je sais pas si les
hamsters court très vite mais nous
allons le savoir grâce à jacques très
malins qui va nous raconter une histoire
d'âme star et chargent de vous raconter
dans les enfants parce qu autrefois on
connaissait linceul abstraire un villa
hamster gris qui habite en alsace et en
allemagne qu'on détestait parce qu'il
fait des stocks énormes dans son terrier
on trouvait 60 81 kg de grains à leur
reprocher quand ian milham ster dans un
champ et reste plus grand chose dans
l'est pas et puis en 1838 il ya un
savant nommé waterhouse qui dans le
désert de syrie là-bas voit un petit
hamster doré comme celui qu'on
connaissait comme les vole un seul il le
voit il le regarde il comprend pas il le
décrit il s'en va son temps après en
un savant d'alexandrie le professeur à à
ronnie va dans le même dr ils
cherchaient des scorpions lui le court
après un scorpion rad soc scorpions
creusent la terre brad ravissant
scorpions et tombe dans un trou sur une
mer hamster et ses douze petits c'était
des hamsters dorés comme les vôtres ces
petits hamsters dorés vous connaissez
tous
vous avez tous eu j'y tiens c'est
l'animal waterhouse avait découvert ce
formidable emails tout dans un peigne et
rentre chez lui et said el mais ces
hamsters la plupart crève et il en
envoie 4 au professeur adler à londres
au muséum de loin au british muséum pour
étudier la vie de ces petits hamsters là
les savants se penche sur ces hamsters
les études il regarde comment sa vie
combien de temps sa porte avant tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur hamster et moi il
le seul figure seulement une hamster ça
se reproduit et à la cadence de six
petits tous les trois mois
au bout de deux ans le british muséum
était plat de hamster c'était l'enfer
heureusement il y avait les gardes du
british muséum il y avait les
professeurs qui avaient des enfants
les gosses de votre âge qui avaient vu
ces hamsters qu'ils aiment c'est joli
comme tout hamster donnez le nous on
leur donne des petits hamsters et les
enfants commencent à étudier le hamster
et ils découvrent sur le mc en tas de
choses
police have on n'avait jamais vu par
exemple que un hamster on peut le
prendre comme on veut quand il a la
bouche pleine vous savez il transporte
ses provisions dans sa bouche à lui fait
des grosses gouttes
alors quand il avait les joues pleines
comme ça on peut le prendre le car et
c'est cette faille chez très facile mais
quand il a vidé sa bouche avec ses
pattes parce qu'ils la vident avec ses
pattes
il vaut mieux faire attention parce
qu'il pourrait peut-être vous mordre et
puis découvre aussi que le hamster est
un véritable pic
mais un pitre quand vous avez un petit
hamster dans votre tasse dans sa cage
vous donner une petite chaise une petite
échelle un tourniquet comme aux
écureuils mais vraiment il fait le clown
mais littéralement pour vous amuser
comme s'ils faisaient exprès et voilà
que les gosses qui raconte ses histoires
sur les hamsters et tout le monde avait
des histoires de accès à la suisse avant
ce 10 mai dans un chien ses enfants il y
avait à ce moment là des millions le
hamster à travers l'angleterre et la
france vous avez tous connus des
hamsters bon et savants se disait
lachens et basson vue sur le hamster
beaucoup de choses que nous n'avions
découverte nous si on allait voir au
désert les vrais hamster les hamsters
sauvage
comment il faut aussi gens aussi
intelligents que ce que les gosses
raconte convoler pour comprendre si
c'était l'éducation tous et c'est
naturel on part on désert de syrie là où
le professeur à ronnie avait trouvé ses
treize hamster on trouve pas on
quadrille le désert mais on le passe
littéralement au peigne fin
on a pu trouver un seul abstraire les 13
hamster que le professeur a à ronnie
avait découvert en 1930 et elle est
dernier de l'espèce et l'espèce qui
compte maintenant des millions et 10
millions du hamster a été littéralement
sauvé parce que vous les gosses vous
avez élevé les hamsters et vous avez
appris à jouer avec eux car des liens
sont des gens absolument charmant
bonjour dans cette émission nous avons
beaucoup parlé des saints bande dessinée
le maul dit il ya beaucoup de dessins
dans une bande dessinée mais ce dessin
en réalité est toujours au service d'une
histoire
alors cette histoire elle s'appelle pas
une histoire vous avez sûrement entendu
prononcer le mot de scénario c'est le
même mot qui sert en bande dessinée au
cinéma d'ailleurs
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un scénario
est bien le scénario c'est ce qui va se
passer
il serait dit au départ exactement comme
une rédaction à l'école il ya un début
de l'histoire
il ya une fin de l'histoire puis il ya
ce qui se passe entre les deux qu'on
appelle le développement
alors là vous vous racontez votre petite
histoire en sachant que vous allez faire
une histoire en bande dessinée de cette
page de huit pages ou de 40 pages
votre récit sera plus ou moins long mais
vous le raconter exactement comme une
rédaction ça fait une ou deux pages
manuscrites
ça c'est la base à partir de là on entre
dans la technique de la bande dessinée
qui s'appelle le découpage
je suis dans un découpage
c'est très mystérieux on y voit des
lettres des colonnes des descriptions du
dialogue
il y a même un code c'est de la chimie
tout ça paraît vraiment être l'univers
des professionnels en réalité il suffit
de connaître certains trucs quand je
vous ai quitté un peu brusquement à
l'instant je me promenais donc dans une
page de scénarios a grandi pour plus
exactement une page découper du scénario
des aventures d'achille talon alors
imaginons que vous êtes scénariste et
vous travaillez avec un dessinateur ceci
ça va servir à vous comprendre entre
vous le scénariste et le dessinateur est
pas destiné au public
alors on indique d'abord le nom de la
série l'histoire et le numéro de la page
à laquelle nous sommes parce que plus il
y aura de pages plus on risque de
confondre
nous avons trois colonnes la première on
va y revenir tout de suite
on y lit des lettres et des chiffres
voilà je fais à 1 2 3 puis je passe à
b12 c'est très mystérieux ici la partie
la plus simple c'est le dialogue c'est
écrit sous forme dactylographié ou autre
ce qui va venir dessiner dans les bulles
dans les ballons quand les personnages
vont parler entre eux dans l'image est
ici au milieu la partie la plus
importante qui est la description écrite
par le scénariste de ce que le
dessinateur va devoir précisément
dessinée alors là ça doit être très
court et pour que ce soit court
il faut qu'on se comprenne du premier
coup le dessinateur a préparé l'autre
bout de la filière imaginons que le
scénariste habite marseille le
dessinateur paris échanges par
correspondance et le dessinateur a
préparé mais déjà des filiales aux îles
cela fait de scénario on verra l'instant
et lui il va traduire tout de suite
alors la première bande
pour lui c'est la bande à l'autre b
l'autre c'est l'autre des ces la page
standard il y a douze images
si le scénariste a prévu qui aurait 12
images on changerait ça va être à 1 à 2
à 3 v 1 d2 d3 et ainsi de suite c'est
exactement comme un la bataille navale
mais imaginons que le scénariste sentent
que il doit s'exprimer à certains
moments dans de grandes images
il en veut une plus grande que
d'habitude et il dit du premier coup à 1
2 le dessinateur a compris à 1 2 l'image
va occuper les deux tiers de la première
bande il y aura une image à 3 puis
reprend à deux mètres
maintenant il faut tout grande je le
scénariste indique ab 1 2 1 2 le
dessinateur aussitôt c'est que son image
va être aussi grande caisse et on va
lire à 3 après petites images normales
b trois petites images normales c'est un
petit images normales up de nouveaux
grands desseins c2 c3
d2 d3 et grâce à ce petit code qu'on
peut perfectionner quand on se connaît
bien en général le sénateur
le dessinateur et scénariste ont un peu
copains enfin il vaut mieux et ils
peuvent entre eux m un code au point un
code personnel
et puis dans les colonnes du milieu les
descriptions d'image on va lire des
termes étrange par exemple un
panoramique
c'est un terme de cinéma a pas de bandes
dessinées apparemment apparemment
seulement bon en cinéma d'abord
qu'est-ce que c'est un panoramique
le plus simple c'est de vous en montrer
s'il vous plaît messieurs un petit
panoramic alors voilà un superbe
panoramique qui vous permet au passage
de découvrir le mobilier extraordinaire
dont nous disposons voilà et on revient
à la bande dessinée où il est très
possible de faire un panoramique
je vous explique comment là on va
imaginer un petit scénario
imaginons sur cette image que notre
héros super gérard au volant de sa
puissante voiture poursuit un bandit
redoutable le bandit redoutable celle
horrible succube et super gérard vakil
le rattrape et j'ai fait déjà un dessin
où on sent qu'il ya du chemin à
parcourir pour super g ral un énorme
chemin si mon dessin est plus grand
l'oeil du lecteur court vers la droite
s'aperçoit que la route reste encore
longue
si j'augmente encore on s'aperçoit que
super gérard va mettre un certain moment
avant de rattraper
l'horrible succube si un moment donné
gagne du terrain
bon panoramique va se raccourcir et on
va sentir que ça devient tangent pour le
succube qui va passer un mauvais quart
d'heure
l'aura pas volé bien il y à d'autres
trucs de cinéma qu'on peut également
appliquer en bande dessinée ou du moins
donner la même impression par exemple
avez vous déjà entendu parler d'un zoom
et bien ou au cinéma c'est ça alors
voilà je fais un très joli zoom est bien
ce zoom on peut le reproduire en bande
dessinée aussi lassé du pab qui m'a
prêté le personnage de publi-t us que
vous connaissez sûrement
alors là on a cubitus à une certaine
distance il vient vers nous et puis
cubitus à la deuxième image se
rapprochent déjà beaucoup et à la
troisième image
il est tout près nous eh bien si ces
trois images sont alignés sur une même
bande
l'oeil du lecteur va faire le travail de
la caméra il va avoir l'impression que
cubitus vient de se rapprocher
terriblement vite et il a fait un zoom
si le scénariste
zoom à son dessinateur le dessinateur
sera traduire en troisième il y a
d'autres noms du cinéma mais vous la
trouvez bien vous même par exemple une
plongée quand ses vues du ciel une
contre-plongée quand vous imaginez que
la caméra est au sol et vous regarder
vers le ciel et le reste je crois que
vous le découvrirez vous même
regardez attentivement les films de
cinéma
vous découvrirez le langage du scénario
le langage de la narration par l'image
filmée ou dessiner
bonjour s'agace les enfants capte sa
grâce sa donne sa grâce
j'allais faire des courses à la portée
des petits cadeaux alors tiens donnera
sa té copains je leur donnais tout de
suite
et puis j'ai apporté des gâteaux pour
miss 4 frags adage n'apportait de alors
malheureusement j'ai demandé aux
boulangers qui me donne des deux gâteaux
là un peu de la même taille mais il y en
a pas trouvé il avait un gros et un
petit alors comme vous avez vous
débrouillez vous entre vous ils ont
l'air très bon tous les deux sens qu'est
ce que tu attends sers toi nous nous
jetons prix de biscottes sers-toi la
première bon bon bah voilà tu ne mets
pas pourquoi mais si tu as des questions
monsieur qui aurait pris le petit tu me
rends à bondues
tu crois ça oui bien sûr si je crois que
j'en suis sûr tu n'es pas contente pas
mal élevés oui mais moi je trouve qu'il
ya quelque chose de vrai dans ce que dit
mascate à madrid en dans le fond un j'ai
bien compris si j'étais poli je prendrai
le petit et je te laisserai le groupe
actuellement et ils toi et tu bien
élevés ou malibu
j'ai reçu une très bonne éducation et
j'estime je suis donc si tu avais dû
choisir en premier
oui tu aurais pris lequel mais j'aurais
pris le petit libyen et puisque tu tu
l'aies le petit alors de quoi te plains
tu as un vraiment
à l'écomusée
dans mon sac une plaque de bons
chocolats dans le mensonge plein jour là
je tombe de lepage cordoba pour pour toi
pas pour toi mais quand on sent copains
torah tout ou presque tout dans son
copain
dans un trou il ya des sous pour acheter
des choses dans un trou bien des sous
pour acheter des choses je te me donnes
pas je te donne pour pour toi avec ton
copain tu auras tout presque tous que
quand son copain dans le frigo il ya des
pots avec de la glace très vivant je
tente de ne pas jeter pas pour toi toi
mais quand on fait un copain
un ton bras tout en ratant presque tous
d'anciens copains dans le buffet y des
jouets mais qu'avec qu'annick buffet
jetant tu donnes pas ton sais pas
pourquoi je dois pour toi mais quand on
sent copains torah taux presque tout
pour rendre son copain dans mon cou il
ya des points qui font la culbute
quand on court un dépôt qui font la
culbute tombe de poids pour toi mais
quand on se repeint tu auras tout ou
presque tout quand un copain
quand on pense aux copains
dans mes tout de suite tout de suite et
bien le premier volet du dossier spécial
non effets spéciaux pardon c'est un
sujet très intéressant il faut donc dire
précisément que ça s'appelle les effets
spéciaux du cinéma et de la télévision
cela va vous être présenté par nicolas
hulot dont vous allez faire tout de
suite la connaissance voilà bien venu
effectivement dans les dossiers de ces
visiteurs du mercredi dossier qu'on
retrouvera régulièrement au cours
desquelles nous traiteront de sujets et
d'autres mais je dois je dois vous dire
tout de suite que nous allons parler
pendant quatre semaines et je rentre
tout de suite dans la matière d'un sujet
sur lequel nous reviendrons donc dans
quatre semaines autant vous dire que
c'est un sujet très intéressant de quoi
allons nous parler
eh bien nous allons parler des effets
spéciaux ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler
les effets spéciaux
c'est un petit peu la magie du cinéma la
magie du film et pour ce faire pour
parler de ses effets spéciaux et bien je
vous propose deux choses tout d'abord
nous avons reçu de walt disney cette
super maison de production américaine
eh bien nous avons reçu d une série de
quatre films que nous verrons
successivement donc le durant ces quatre
semaines et vous verrez au travers de
ces quatre séries de films au cours
desquelles d'ailleurs vous retrouverez
des personnages de ces héros dessinés de
ses dessins animés de walt disney a
rendu célèbre et puis nous retrouverons
des extraits de films de films de walt
disney qui sont déjà parus ou qui vont
paraître
et puis également nous aurons avec tout
daniel vieille mère je ne vous en dit
pas trop sur lui je vous dirai seulement
que d'habitude il n'est pas à cet
endroit du plateau il est plutôt
derrière nous en régie elle et lui mère
est ce qu'on appelle dans notre métier
un truc listées dans les visiteurs du
mercredi ils opèrent souvent dans ces
petits trucs dans cette magie du cinéma
et de la télévision
alors je ne vous en dis pas plus sachez
seulement qu'on va voir tout de suite
l'un de ces de ses premiers l'une de ses
premières séries de ces quatre films de
walt disney alors je vous demande de
prêter toute votre attention car vous
allez voir les effets spéciaux se
déroule en cascade à leur tâche est de
ne manquer aucun
c'est
oui
salut à tous
aujourd'hui c'est un studio trois
spéciales que je vous propose
studio 3 spécial rock français avec en
grande majorité des tournages fait par
notre équipe nous verrons pierre chérèze
les dogs jean patrick capdevielle sapho
jean falissard les sex pistols mabéa et
bernard lavilliers alors à juste titre
vous vous demandez probablement pourquoi
dans ce studio 3 spécial rock français
je ne vous annonce pas trust téléphone
ou starshooter qui sont quand même les
trois plus célèbres groupes français
mais ya une raison très simple c'est que
trust et téléphone on les retrouvera la
semaine prochaine et starshooter était
enlevée avec nous en direct
il y a quinze jours soleil